I'm going to show you my my proof here
the three things we want to get to okay
I will point out this is only one mark
and really you just try to get you you
should get to part three if I plot three
is the real question parts 1 & 2 are the
exams said in saying here we want to
sort of give you a nudge in the right
direction and not just leave you
directionless ok so there are lots of
ways to go about this but I'll show you
my way you're keeping with part one is
that the verb of the question the verb
but the question is have a look at it
what I ask you to do explain well you
hardly ever ask you to explain in a
mathematics exam so you've got to use
some words here you must use words if
there are no words in what you've
written for part one I'm doubtful then
you wouldn't get a mark even if there
are lots of right things in your
solution to power one so here's my
explanation okay I'm looking at Zed -
that's this guy okay and I'm comparing
it to a that's it this guy over here ok
just a short note you've got P Q and
high which other points and that you've
got Zed ones into an age and a complex
numbers representing your points so what
I'm going to say is being that both is
into an egg inhabit this triangle up
here I go what kind of triangle is
equilateral right so I'm going to say
since I'm using words C sits triangle o
Q R is equilateral
since its equilateral I can make an
argument about each of the angles in it
now remember I am in radians land right
so I can say and equilateral triangle
each of its angles is pi/3 radians it's
all the nice things about using radians
I'm gonna have to think about 180 60 45
what is it you just go pi divided by
whatever you want it to be okay so the
three angles they all have two pi so pi
on three each now if that is the case
then I can say that OQ that vector in
fact I'm going to put an hour on that
just to give me AB you know treating as
a vector is the same as thinking use of
our R and rotating it in what direction
what actually my going in that way
that's AG clockwise right which is the
positive direction is same as rotating
anti-clockwise by PI on 3 radians I just
explained that right so therefore I can
say pants Oh
q do you remember what's the way that I
indicate it's a vector I'm not just like
a length power yeah I have an arrow on
the top right and it's owed to Q rather
huge overs those are two vectors right
hence oku is formed by rotating which
picked up my face now the vector I'm
thinking about is o and I'm going to
rotate that by the final three which is
where don't use me to come okay so I'll
get this double unison it's formed by
rotating ah by PI on 380 clockwise that
direction is really important and in
your explanation you've got to say it
one of the critical problems that
students have as they work with vector
questions is why I brought it out is not
accounting for direction right in a
minute for part two I'm going to talk
about going clockwise and so my
calculations are going to be ever so
slightly different right so just be
watchful okay now here's a reason so I
am going to provide
an equation that tells me that right so
a Q equals now rotations of complex
numbers in vectors is formed by one
operation it's multiplication right so
I'm gonna go times now what's the
complex number that will rotate me pile
three radians in the clockwise direction
and the answer is caused by other
because I saw three on the right that do
you see and I am mention this to a
couple of you just yeah right whenever
you're doing jima squeezing of any kind
you'll have any credence somewhere and
your reason should basically be a
restatement of that equation right so
the example I always hear is that if you
are had coma Tyria and goes on parallel
lines you might say something like alpha
plus beta equals 180 degrees right now
your reasoning would be Co interior
angles on parallel lines are
supplementary okay now often we see
something like this maybe
alpha is like the angle you actually
want fine so we kind of take a shortcut
and we like our it's just that right but
I don't write this because that has
nothing to do with figs adding together
and the left-hand side doesn't have Co
interior angles on it it's got one of
the co interior angles so if I wrote
this and said no interior angles or
parallel lines of supplementary there is
a mismatch between the equation I've
written versus the reason I provided can
you see my second and third lines are
basically saying the same thing it was
then in symbols do you see that at
Tysons so that's what makes the logic of
at one time I came now I'm gonna replace
it with all I pretty much done right
this is the complex numbers at you
that's a so I've got these down all over
but that's done right and I think that's
okay right is my explanation
I hope you're content with that you have
a look I need to get to this next one
z1 z2 equal a squared I've got that too
damn my pocket yeah I just have to worry
about zip one now I can do this in two
different ways I actually referred
before to do we man we're taking the
clockwise direction I couldn't talk
about that way
alternatively being that I just did part
one do you notice that I can for part
two I can almost do part one all over
again
right because oh-ah oh-ah is our PE we
retained an antique off lines by the
same angle it's done done all over again
right so anytime you've got geometric
reasoning if you've done some trend
reuse it because then you'd have to say
don't learn it right so I could say
similarly that's such a good word
similarly you know I've got the same
equation triangle down the bottom you
can take over so I could say oh what a
my god oh ah is formed by retaining he
in the same way
okay so because I kind of laid that
point I'm gonna go straight to the
complex number four so the complex
number representing oh you are sorry is
8 that's hey then the complex number
representing oh hey is say 1 and then
that time of 380 clockwise rotation is
going to be W yep okay so what we're
gonna do in these what's my next step
anyone who am I gonna go I'm gonna have
to substitutes of something to here
right it's one more thing before I do
that I don't have said one to substitute
I just have to treat that a little bit
I'm going to divide both sides by and
from here it's all trivial isn't it to
get to zip 1 set 2 I just as long as it
suggested I'm just going to substitute
the V there is a 1 there's it to so as
required you happy